well the organic movement has really
grown its it went from a three billion
dollar market in nineteen ninety five to
13 billion dollars in ten years later
and while some of us are concerned about
the use of the word organic and its
applications being a little bit muddied
and actually marketed taken and marketed
by huge food companies that said it is a
crucial movement for us and people like
Walmart the company like Walmart
embracing organic is kind of a
tremendous sea change and one that I'm
really applauding of course there isn't
enough organic food to actually sustain
Walmart's needs which is an amazing
thing and of itself and one thing that's
fantastic about Walmart embracing
organics is that it's going to drive
down the price of organic food that is
one problem with organic food is that it
really up until now it's really been the
province of the of the wealthy because I
love whole foods for instance most of
the food is organic or tries to get food
from within the area that is organic so
kind of it tries to a spouse that look
of our philosophy however everything is
extremely expensive and it's it's very
difficult for most people to kind of
live an organic life with those prices
so something like Walmart creating
organic section is going to help this
country really embrace that movement
even more I'm hoping that the standards
will stay as strict and rigid as they
are now of course there is a huge
pressure from lobbyists in Washington to
change that and to to bring the
standards down and that is very
worrisome but there's a very vocal
community in this country that will
resist that and if we continue to be
vocal about it then hopefully organics
standards will remain for very strict